martin biron michel david stéphanie
grammond bon choix bonsoir bonsoir on ne
peut pas ne pas parler de suie verdict
pour la belle mère de la petite fille de
green bay
coupable sur toute la ligne tour de
table martin je le disais d'entrée de
jeu il ya eu ça choque et ça a secoué le
québec ait eu cette commission où on
verra ce que ça donne enfin on l'a vu à
un projet de loi déposé pour moderniser
la dpj il ya ce procès de la belle-mère
le procureur va l'entendre en quelques
secondes mais on dit c'est la seule
façon de rendre un peu de dignité à
cette jeune fille que cette mort là en
tout cas serve à quelque chose
martin je pensais qu'on écouter
l'extrait désolé qu'il en est oui c'est
sûr que le le décès de cette petite
fille l'a bousculé beaucoup le
gouvernement de françois legault a dès
le début du mandat le gouvernement de
françois legault voulait mettre en place
une commission parlementaire pour
réformer la dpj alors quand cette petite
fille l'un est décédé à bousculer les
choses et gouvernement s'est vraiment
mis à la tâche et on peut dire qu'ils
ont a si bien réussi leur coup parce que
bon régine laurent quand même diriger
cette commission
dans kate avec une main de fer et le
ministre lionel cavin quand même loin
des feux de la rampe à monter ce projet
de loi qui met l'intérêt de l'enfant au
coeur de la protection de la jeunesse ça
l'air de rien il a eu plusieurs
critiques et beaucoup de gens qui disent
eh ben oui mais l'intérêt de l'enfant
est déjà considéré mais la loi va
changer si bien que l'intérêt de
l'enfant c'est peut-être qu'ils ne
soient plus avec ses parents biologiques
en tout cas dans le cas de cette petite
fille là si elle n'avait pas hésité avec
sa mère biologique peut être que les
choses auraient été différentes
alors la loi ne permettait pas ce genre
de décision là alors on s'envole à et je
peux vous dire que monsieur le goût est
très très satisfait de ce projet de loi
là quand il a été déposé à l'assemblée
nationale d'ailleurs le québec solidaire
s'est levé le parti québécois s'élevait
à seulement les numéros qui ont rien dit
c'est une réforme majeure qui a été
proposé avec la réforme des pays et qui
émanent je le rappelle bien sûr qu'on
n'a pas de découvert cette journée là
grâce au drame qu'il y avait des choses
à réformer la dpj mais la mort de cette
jeune fille l'a été un catalyseur
challes david pour faire accélérer les
réformes qu'on voulait faire oui tout à
fait et vous savez la caq avant qu'elle
prenne le pouvoir et même dans les
premiers mois du gouvernement de gaulle
et jean un des reproches qu'on lui
faisait c'était de manquer d'empathie un
manque d'empathie envers un peu tout le
monde le finalement dans le code de ce
drame là et face aux jeunes de façon
générale je pense que le gouvernement a
bien réagi la réaction était rapide
madame nora enfin bon travailler et le
gouvernement a vraiment donné
l'impression qu'il voulait faire quelque
chose au total
je pense que politiquement ccc réussi
comme come test disons pour le
gouvernement legault et pour la société
en général
on verra jusqu'à quel point ces mesures
le vote efficace moi je trouve toujours
ça un peu fatiguant de voir que sauf
erreur là directeur national de la santé
publique va demeurer un sous-ministre un
peu comme monsieur arruda mais de façon
générale la réaction était bonne bon
stéphanie oui mais c'est effectivement
je pense que on s'entend pour dire que
la commission laurent le projet de loi
est tous a
satisfait les acteurs en présence c'est
très bien parce que dans le passé il y
avait eu probablement une dizaine de
commissions plus de deux comités
d'experts qui avait été mandatée pour
s'occuper de cette réforme là de la dpj
puis absolument je dirais pas rien il
n'y a pas grand-chose qui avait bougé
est faute de fonds faute de suivi et ça
va faire en sorte que quand même le
nombre d'enfants à la dpj avait doublé
en 25 ans donc ce n'était pas c'était
pas glorieux on espère que là on a
vraiment marqué un point tournant donc
oui des belles avancées mais ya encore
énormément de chemin à faire parce que
on sait à la dpj il manque de lits
manquent de bras y manque d'intervenants
il faut revaloriser c'est une profession
leur si on veut que ça soit pas des
portes tournantes puis qu'on ait des
intervenants qui soit assez nombreux qui
soit pas épuisé pour prendre en charge
parce que c'est trop facile le ce
travail là et donc on veut qu'ils
puissent le faire comme il faut c'est
pas c'est pas vrai que
les tout le monde doit aller à la dpj ça
devrait les soins intensifs si on veut
pas la première ligne dont vous investir
aussi en première ligne pour désengorger
et les la dpj et sur le plan judiciaire
je le disais la personne qui sort
aujourd'hui du palais de justice de
trois-rivières en 1ère grosse victoire
bravo c'est d'une tristesse infinie des
deux côtés et le procureur bussières qui
s'appelle
le mieux résumé je disais plus tôt la
journée
cette culpabilité la de meurtre au
deuxième degré c'est un signal qu'on
envoie cette jeune fille dont les cotes
d'écouté c'est c'est beaucoup d'émotions
et si ce verdict et leurs
rangs un peu de dignité à cette jeune
fille c'est déjà énorme
martin ça résume bien c'est que personne
les procureurs à était émue pour le bus
était au duel on a décrit les horreurs
tout au long de ce procès amélie notre
journal est tous les jours après jours
entendait des choses dures
et là ils ont réussi quand même de façon
exemplaire à ce que justice soit faite
selon elles entre que selon la preuve
mais c'est le système il ya des failles
dans le système puis il il faut faillir
encore c'est un peu notre horreur
l'a21 roar gagnon de des temps modernes
c'est quand même en 1920 puis sentant
plus tard on a encore un cas
très très grave et
c'est ça le sida seuil est de -
passibles de que le système faillite et
c'est qu'on soit capable de relever le
défi je trouvais ça intéressant ce que
disait stéphanie sait que c'est une
grosse machine
la dpj c'est une grosse machine s'est
beaucoup de gens qui entourent les
enfants et ça demande une
de s'arrimer avec la police avec les
écoles avec les familles et c'est un
gros défi c'est bien beau d'avoir un
cadre bon projet de loi mais de mettre
tous les morceaux de castets ensemble il
savait tout un défi est une tâche énorme
il faut le dire monsieur david et c'est
fanny pour n'importe quel état que de
palier aussi aux drames familiaux à
l'incapacité parentale à
l'irresponsabilité parentale ses potes
de tout repos mais xavi les familles
vous avez raison le sourire et un manque
de bras ceux qui sont là ils sont
débordés et puis c'est dick aussi dur
comme c'est vrai dans tout système de
santé mais vous avez c'est vrai de façon
générale on l'a vu bon les éducatrices
des hôpitaux la dpj dans ce cas-ci ce
qu'est ce que j'ai trouvé quand même
fascinant là au cours de tout ce
processus là ce que cet événement là à
déclencher un espèce de sentiment de
culpabilité collective tout le monde on
s'est dit mais comment ça se fait que ça
peut arriver au québec en 2010 19 quand
c'est arrivé
ça qui est un sentiment que ça n'a pas
de bon sens et je pense que ce sentiment
là est suffisamment fort pour que en
tout cas dans l'avenir immédiat
il ya des pressions pour qu'il y ait des
résultats et que du personnel s'ajoute
évidemment ça dépend aussi des
conditions que le gouvernement incapable
de faire pauvre rendre ce travail-là
attirant il est clair qu'il ya des gens
qui ont la vocation mais il ya des
limites la travailler dans des
conditions impossibles
disons que je suis relativement confiant
mais
il va falloir que la pression demeure la
pression collective si on veut oui faut
pas attendre d'autres d'autres drames
vous m'amenez je veux changer le plan
vous allez me pardonner vous allez me
suis dit professionnel au cac la
stratégie de monsieur legault de s'en
prendre à un ado du bois
je vais garder ça pour demain pour mon
panel demain je vais aller tout de suite
à la laquette plq que c'était la fin de
session bilan avec madame anglade il
monsieur legault parce que je prends la
balle au bond michel vous dit le drame
la fillette on veut pas que ça se
reproduise ce qu'on veut pas que se
reproduise non plus c'est ce qui arrivé
ce qui est arrivé dans les sièges à
celle du ca dépasse la joute partisane
ça dépasse la petite politique c'est
comme une prise de conscience est ce que
dans la joute politique jusqu'à combien
de temps ça va se répercuter
on écoute les changes que madame anglade
c'était hier avec nous sur le gros
est ce que le premier ministre qui était
chef de la cellule de crise était le
seul à ne pas être au courant qu'on
allait à l'abattoir dans nos ch et celle
du tout le monde cherchait d'équipement
donc monsieur président dès qu'on a eu
de l'information à alger le premier
ministre ne répond pas à la question je
demande au premier ministre s'est levé
juste quand même spécial d'antan achève
le position ciel après la semaine
kalinka mal de demandes et de s'élever
monsieur legault fait référence au mot
abattoirs qui utilisaient madame anglade
indien bon qu'est ce que ça nous dit
martin ça cet échange la mesure où on
s'en va dans ce débat dès 6h sld à
l'assemblée nationale les partis
d'opposition veulent se démarquer là
dessus ça fait des semaines qu'il frappe
sur ce clou là il ya peu près je sais
pas moi une trentaine de paires de
questions à la période des questions ici
à peu près
25 qui porte sur la situation dans les
ca chez cdc tout notre collègue thomas
gerber a donné des munitions l'avait en
révélant les courriels qui démontrait
que le gouvernement avait été informé
que livre c'est ch et s'est dit est
vulnérable alors ils frappent ce le clou
jour après jour mais abandonnée veulent
garder l'histoire vivante et on va assez
loin madame anglade a beaucoup monté en
fait sorti beaucoup de gros mots
remarqué que monsieur le goût est assez
bon dans ce jeu là aussi et on veut
pousser monsieur legault dans une
situation où on aura cette enquête
publique a lancé la fin de la session et
on veut marquer les ex les esprits pour
qu'autour de la dden durant les vacances
de noël on parle justement d'une
vêtements ou de la façon de la gestion
des ch et ses dépens dans la première
vague par le gouvernement le groupe
shenzhen est ce que c'est un présage ce
qui va continuer à arriver après où on
vend on donne le tout pour le tout
lappion si on est conscient que il ya
peut-être une fin en soi non je pense ça
va continuer au printemps la coroner va
reprendre ses audiences on verra ce qui
en sortira elles vont remettre un
rapport et on peut déjà penser que le
rapport ce repos
très positif pour le gouvernement on
voit embrasser sa et et comme s'il a peu
près le seul la seule faille le que le
gouvernement
qui est apparu ils ont au cours
du mandat finalement c'est la première
fois que le gouvernement est constamment
sur la défensive mais quand on a dit ça
on regarde que de façon générale les
gens sont tous d'accord pour dire que ce
l'épouvantable ce qui est arrivé d'un
sachet cd mais quand on regarde
l'appréciation générale de la gestion de
la pandémie on voit que le gouvernement
conserve encore un taux de satisfaction
extrêmement élevé et les gens tout en se
désolant je pense apprécié l'action du
gouvernement en fonction de ce que ça
représentait pour eux alors pour les
gens les parents des victimes dans des
sachets cd c'est épouvantable mais de
façon générale les gens ont le sentiment
que somme toute ça aurait pu être bien
pire et on s'en tire pas si mal et ça me
fait croire que malgré les efforts
répétés et ça va continuer jusqu'à
l'élection et y compris pendant la
campagne
sané bras le repas de gouvernement et je
dois beaucoup qu'il finisse par se
résigner à a commandé une enquête
ordonnée une enquête publique c'est pas
la même chose qu'au moment où jean
charest était pris avec la corruption
dans l'industrie de la construction
monsieur charest était très impopulaire
à ce moment là il en est à son troisième
mandat c'est vraiment pas la situation
dans laquelle monsieur legault surtout
aujourd'hui soit vous êtes y en europe
au lieu de deux comme son enquête
stéphanie sur 7
sur cette répétition de la taxe sur les
sièges celle des croyez vous aussi que
ça va continuer l'on n'a pas fini
j'ai l'impression que oui mais en même
temps je pense
je suis bien d'accord avec ce cas
michèle dit c'est qu'il ya la cape une
armure incroyable c'est comme si on a en
personne réussi à la percée mais là dans
les derniers sondages qui dans l'opinion
on voit que
la gestion des ch et celle des sites une
faille qui ce qui se dessine tout comme
l accès ou ou au médecin puis à la
première ligne donc là il ya le parti
libéral qui évidemment et c'est deux
essais d'entrée par cette fin mai mais
en même temps commis par tout le temps
sur le même clou les plates une certaine
lassitude n'est plus là madame en
anglais d une surenchère dans son
vocabulaire qui est peut-être pas très
judicieuse
pour pour dire le moins je pense que la
caq ne fera pas de commission enquête
même si ce serait peut-être souhaitable
c'est vrai qu'on a déjà plusieurs
enquêtes qui font la preuve que le
travail se fait longtemps on en obtient
l'information en d'un côté on se dit à
quoi bon avoir avoir une commission
encore par dessus qui mobiliserait le
tout l'appareil et gouvernementales
pendant des mois d'élections est-ce que
les joueurs avez-vous vu des sondages
là-dessus mais je vous pose la question
1 naïvement que j'en ai pas vus voulez
vous que le gouvernement legault lahonce
une autre comme une commission d'
enquête publique sur ce qui peut se
passer dans les sièges des cd on n'a pas
vu sur martin j'ai toujours dit
oui ils ont sondé mais le calendrier les
favorise à certains égards parce qu'on
est à moins d'un an des élections
le rapport de la coroner le rapport du
commissaire à la santé alors quand il va
être capable de tenir le coup jusqu'à ce
que ces rapports le soient déposées et
après on va être presque rendu à
l'élection alors peut-être que ce sera
un enjeu de campagne électorale bon et
le danger peut-être comme dit stéphanie
pour l'opposition de ne parler que de ça
mais on verra les phénomènes de fin de
session le la bouilloire la température
qui monte également dans les termes
utilisés demain mesdames et messieurs on
va faire le bilan des autres partis et
de cette nouvelle stratégie du monsieur
legault de s'en prendre à nadeau dubois
puis ce combat on va parler demain merci
à vous trois au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i see her dit